two weeks from today people in the
philippines will go to the polls to vote
for a new president some observers are
calling it one of the most important
elections in the country's history a
number of candidates are standing but
only two appear to have any chance of
winning
the favorite is ferdinand marcos jr he's
the son of the former dictator who was
ousted in 1986 after being accused of
repression and stealing billions of
dollars from the state latest surveys
show marcos jr on 56 percent of the vote
his closest rival lenny robredo is on 24
analysts say the campaigns are being
driven more by personality rather than
ideology but robredo says she sees it as
her task to save democracy in the
philippines
we'll have more on the candidates in a
moment but first a report from manila on
how catholic priests are weighing in on
the campaigns
this man in pink is actually a priest
but he's not on these streets to
evangelize
he's here preaching politics carrying
posters and stickers instead of a bible
father not balthazar
is campaigning for philippines vice
president lenny roberto ahead of next
month's presidential election she's
running a distance second in the polls
to fernand marcos jr the son of namesake
of the country's late dictator we have
to be
wise in choosing a candidate who can
promote good to each one of us and not
the evil ones
this monument near manila commemorates
the people power protests in 1986 which
drove the marcos family into exile for
several years the family is accused of
stealing as much as 10 billion from the
government while marcos senior was in
power almost half of his two-decade
reign was under martial law when
thousands of people were tortured killed
or disappeared
marcus jr refuses to address the
atrocities and dismisses questions about
his own conviction for income tax
evasion as well as the almost four
billion dollars in estate taxes that his
family has long owed the government
balthazar belongs to a group of more
than 1200 priests nuns and missionaries
who have abandoned neutrality in this
race to support robredo
during a recent sunday mass in his
church balthazar referred to an
aggressive social media campaign by
supporters of marcos jr he accuses them
of trying to rewrite history
it was said that the martial law years
was the golden age balthazar says adding
maybe only for the cronies maybe only
for the marcos family
but in a country which is 80 catholic
there's controversy over where priests
should draw the line an official in the
catholic bishops conference told dw
priests must speak the truth about human
rights violations that happened during
martial law but they should not be
campaigning for any particular candidate
this parishioner in baltizard's church
was critical of him publicly taking
sides i agree that the priests shouldn't
be campaigning or shouldn't be biased to
any candidates father balthazar plays
down those concerns the role of the
catholic church
we have to be the promoters of good news
the gospel
that's why we have to promote the good
candidates and not the bad one
balthazar has even outfitted a van for
his campaigning he drives around his
province showing solidarity with the
robredo faithful and trying to convert
supporters of ferdinand marcos jr
he says to this man i'm here trying to
explain to you if you could reconsider
your choice
the response
i'm sorry my decision is final i am for
marcos sad to say uh they are easily
swayed with the tick tocks with the
youtube with the social media they are
watching
and so he keeps on campaigning
as the clock ticks down to election day
hoping that enough votes go his
candidate's way
and joining me now for more from manila
is journalist jc gottinger jc fernand
marcos jr is currently leading in
opinion polls despite his family's
legacy and a conviction for income tax
evasion uh
how and what is his offer to filipinos
well ferdinand marcos jr we call him
bong bong first up he's teamed up with
the daughter of the current president
rodrigo duterte her name is sarah
duterte and they are running in tandem
so the voter base of duterte's and of
the marcoses have kind of joined
together and that is the premise of
their pitch to the country to voters
which is unity they call themselves the
unit team and in their sorties and all
of their campaign materials they have
been just promoting this idea of unity
unity about what and unity of whom they
don't exactly explain
but they're drawing from this vague idea
of the
country's politics being so fraught with
conflict and opposing views um the
atmosphere being so toxic so enough
marcos is promising we're gonna get rid
of all that we are going to to uh
establish unity in the country and with
unity we are going to rise up again so
he gives these vague promises of rising
back from whatever crisis the
philippines is in
um without saying it he is hearkening
back to
uh nostalgia for the so-called good old
days of his father's regime of course
you know
nostalgia makes things look rosy and
there is this machinery there is this
campaign of this information that have
basically whitewashed the marcos
family's history and have highlighted
you know the fact that they live like
royalty they have come to be associated
with opulence and big ticket projects
and flashy
uh infrastructure development during
uh the time of demarcus of course
without mentioning the fact that the
country went into bad debt during those
times and all of those things the
country plunging into poverty all of
these
are hidden behind the screen this battle
cry of unity and the promise of going
back to the good old days more
prosperous days yes
jesse i do want to talk to you about
that particularly about this veneer that
is being propagated uh on social media
but before that i'd just like to talk
about his challenger who is currently
running second in the race in the
opinion polls vice president current
vice president leni robredo what is her
pitch to voters
well her promise is the exact opposite
of what marco says what
marcos jr is promising and that is a
a government free of corruption a
government that works properly in
service of the country so her tagline
her pitch to the country is uh it's
called
which basically translates to with a
government that's honest everyone's
lives uh is going to improve so for her
uh her basic her although she does have
many programs that she wants to put
forward uh her main pitch is that we're
going to fix this government we're going
to weed out corruption and if we do that
if we only just make things make the
bureaucracy work properly then you will
see that everyone's lives is going to
improve
uh i'd like to go back to the point
about misinformation that you were
making earlier that also the report that
we've played
for our viewers is also making about
social media misinformation during this
election uh in fact late last year i had
spoken to nobel prize winning journalist
and rappler ceo maria rasa about this
and i'd just like to play for our
viewers what she said to us then
35 years after the marcos family was was
tossed out of the philippines by a
people power revolt
ferdinand marcos jr bongbong
is running for president so you know in
2019 rappler actually exposed the
networks of disinformation that had been
created to chip away at history to
reorient history and i can share that i
can share the links with you but you
know this is going to be a battle for
facts and we're going to have to make
sure that facts win and in order to do
that these american social media
platforms are going to have to put guard
rails and prioritize facts
jesse of course maria was referring to
facebook particularly which is so
popular in the philippines but the
question remains have guardrails
been put up across social media so facts
can be shared and not misinformation
well the short answer is no more no than
yes there have been some efforts to
combat misinformation
on social media particularly facebook
facebook has employed or has her
collaborated with journalists to do um
on fact check initiative so there are
there are journalists to fact check
this information on the internet and
counter them with facts however the
broader reality is there still are no
rules or laws regulating the posting
of
this information on the internet besides
uh what's inherent in facebook the
mechanism to report upcoming report
messages or posts that violate community
standards but beyond that there isn't
anything even the philippines has not uh
made any effort to come up with the law
to regulate social media in general
there are laws governing
political advertising on all media
platforms except social media because
the technology is so new and even the
government is having a hard time keeping
up with it it's just not been the
priority so uh yes any efforts to that
is a is a drop in the bucket honestly uh
i mean maria was also talking about this
and you were talking you were talking to
us about this a little while earlier as
well particularly when it comes to the
marcos campaign there is this whole uh
veneer this
disinformation of the glory days if you
like of the dictatorship
what is driving this i mean is this
from the marcos campaign or is it just
ordinary voters who believe what they
believe
that is the big question isn't it so
let's start with in january twitter took
down some 300 accounts on their platform
that were spreading promoting this
information
uh favorable to marcos jr so whether
those were
fueled bankrolled by the marcoses it's
for anyone to guess uh but we do know
that efforts like these require a lot of
money uh there have been as maria said
they've there have been discovered uh
troll armies um um it's called marketed
disinformation uh an organized way of
spreading uh fake news basically
favorable to the marcos but there has
been you know the public has picked up
on this the average filipino many
ordinary filipinos have taken through
this messaging and are themselves
spreading uh these bits of
disinformation like wildfire on social
media
two weeks to go until the election on
election day we i'm sure we'll be
speaking again journalist jessica in
manila thanks so much